[Music]
I just noticed during the last break via
Twitter multiple reporters covering the
Dolphins pointing out that Brian Flores
the new coach in Miami has canceled the
final mandatory minicamp practice they
will do conditioning work instead you
know Chris I was talking about this
earlier in the week on the PFT p.m.
podcast I don't understand how coaches
complain that they don't have enough
time in the offseason to work with their
players and then they cancel practices
unless like always plan to cancel a
practice is like a camaraderie thing or
just to give the players a you know a
reward for working hard so no matter how
many practices there are they'll always
cancel one I just still have a hard time
with this idea that they don't think
they have enough practice time and then
they voluntarily sacrifice mandatory
practice time no I I hear you Mike it is
a little weird I know I was a part of a
few instances like that where I you know
whether I was playing or even then I got
done playing more yeah I mean oh gosh we
don't have enough time wish we had more
time with these guys and then yeah the
last day of practice gets cutoff and you
go well ma'am we just you know let it
six hours of more preparation for the
season get away but I think it's it's
more than that it's more than just the
one day that the coaches are concerned
with I think realistically you know
first thing is as you know we know
anybody knows that's following football
the coaches are in heart attack mode
right now anyways they're just going oh
gosh I hope everybody stays healthy and
we don't lose somebody by the time
training camp gets here so they get
towards the end of the finish line and
they just want to get there and get to
the get to training camp unscathed I
think the other thing with what the
coaches are saying I think they're
crying getting to this point gun okay
this one practice isn't gonna matter you
know I think they want more teachable
moments throughout the offseason whether
players got to get there earlier in the
offseason or the rules are just a little
different to where you can have more
meaning time in the classroom or
walkthroughs on the field more teachable
moments like that I think that are
ultimately really frustrating coaches
and right on cue multiple reporters
pointing out the Jets have canceled yeah
their final practice of the three day
mandatory minicamp they're holding an
off-site team activity so whether
they're going bowling or going to the
movies or whether playing laser tag or
paintball or whatever
does that really help III think it does
but you lived it right does it how much
does it help bond players together when
you get away from work and you go do
something like that as a group it is uh
it does work it's it's shockingly
awesome really because it's you know
again NFL players are grown men you know
when you get out of the locker room and
the day's work is done you kind of go to
your different ways you know everybody's
got their own little clique a little bit
as like oh the DBS might hang out
together or defensive guys so not
everybody's all together when you have
these camaraderie moments makes you get
on the team bus you might sit next to a
group of guys you normally don't and you
start to find out about guys and it
starts to be you know you start to get
ba you know bonds and trust and get to
know someone guys you might not know on
the roster and some situations that you
know you're both unfamiliar with and I
do I really do think it is very
important for players and it has great
value within the locker room and really
just the overall Mon you know state of
the franchise to keep everybody kind of
normal sane and realizing this is fun
and we're human beings what's the best
team activity that that you were ever
involved oh gosh well I mean Jeff Fisher
always had you know great you know
Thanksgiving Day pranks and things like
that where he'd send the rookies to go
get turkeys and Thanksgiving and they
thought they were bringing back turkeys
to the facility to help like a great
cause and there would be a bag of ice in
the box and they'd be like oh no I
didn't bring the turkey back like some
of that stuff was great as far as
jokester but Gruden did a great job of
like bringing us to the bowling alley
and having it all set up bowling alley
all for the team we got food and drinks
set up and we'd go over there for three
or four hours and have a little
competition set it up too you know we
had teams and everybody was mixed
together there was just some of the best
times in my life really a lot of laughs
and a lot of a lot of good moments and
that's how you create the environment
where guys have each other's phone
numbers they communicate with each other
a separate and apart from work yes and
they just they they feel a greater
connection to each other and a greater
desire to make sure that they're not
letting each other down and that's all
about crafting a team and I think in
this day and age in the
fell it's critical because every year
the team is dramatically different so
you have your steps every season to
bring your guys together you're right
it's not the old days you know a lot of
these guys you know you could be the
quarterback of a football team and they
sign a free-agent safety and here you
are five weeks into you know offseason
program and you go damn I even really
talked to this guy I don't even know if
he's married he's got kids whatever it
is and sometimes it's these little
gatherings that oh wow I do like this
guy hey maybe we'll have you and the
wife over for a barbecue in a few days
and that's how it kind of all starts and
that's part of football football family
Mike football weighs family we're doing
hey take off Chris you've earned it yes
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports